our church got vbs this week y'all got
any good vbs stories i know y'all both
grew up
going to that vbs vacation bible school
well i didn't hear that game
what do you talk about vbs uh i haven't
talked about it much man
my dad you know what that stands for
vacation bible school yeah yeah yeah my
dad would take us over there and we'd
make a lot of arts and crafts
yeah yeah it was arts and crafts every
dude
the lord is in the glue dog oh man there
was but that was just the k
the there were chicks there though oh
100 100
but they did they didn't your family
didn't know what to do with you during
the summer
no and they send you they did anything
yarn camp
anything dude horse cam yeah explorer
cam
yeah boys treasure hunt nothing doesn't
matter
yeah take these kids reformed pedophile
me
something yeah yeah like i wonder what i
wonder how like you know like if you
like
botany so this guy looks like a decent
man like a good baptist
guy if he's probably from the south so
then you get a step away
yeah i could see him at least a
pentecostal or one of those new churches
you get a step so the pentecostal he's
like a step and he keeps stepping away
yeah then you get jehovah's witnesses
then you get into like you get two
then it's then it's the snake you're
wearing an iverson jersey yeah then
there's their snake hand
then you go so i wonder how far away
from traditional christianity were your
parents that desperate to send you to
camp that they would have said hey
yeah yeah snake handling church
take the kids dude it might not have
been christian as much as it was like
take these kids no i'm dead seriously
yeah dude oh you know like hey what are
you teaching them yeah
yeah it's free you're taking these kids
for free
i don't care what you're teaching them
because some of those songs so southern
churches
it gets dicey it gets quick very quickly
it's real interesting man and you're
like hey get get on
yeah vbs growing up was i used to i used
to work at them in college
yeah in college i went to one in new
orleans
i worked in the inner city new orleans
teaching at vbs really and in new york
city
i did one and i mean dude it was
there was no rules out there because
it's tricky because somebody else
when you work at a church and you're
like a missionary somebody else's when
when your boss is paying you but it's
not there
it's the human being was not set up for
that
you're like yo i'm gonna work in in
nicaragua but my boss is in louisiana
you wanna set the alarm no i don't no
i'm not setting the alarm tomorrow
dude that's funny my dad's family was in
nicaragua doing missionary work when
when his parents where was the money
coming from i don't know
and there probably wasn't much money
back then i think it was 1910
[Laughter]
now here's a weird thing i did in
relationships i painted a chair at
vacation bible school camp
and gave it to a girl like 17 years
later as an adult
and then look if you want to
end the relationship and end up on at
least a list
in a woman's head some kind of list give
her
a chair you painted as a child
16 years earlier as an adult dry
and also drive it five hours to her dude
but again in your mind you were acting
right this guy randy
when i was in vacation bible school he
said he was from the other church
he would come over he was like he was a
he had a red sports car
and he was you know when you at that age
you you
the guy's in his 30s late 30s 40s and
he's single he's cool but
now you're like why didn't this guy now
he's us where was his family
right yeah yeah yeah looking back on it
when your youth pastor is 25
and hanging with us at on friday nights
where
right where are your who's your squad
right is it us and so this guy randy
would come he was a bigger guy he would
always uh
make randy bro he would wear shirts oh
cool
in the to swim oh he you would wear
shirts yeah but like
not a lot like darker like darker like a
black
black no white guy but black shirt oh
meaning you could see through
if you know what i'm saying okay so
that's golden balor
so he would do like you know he went off
to high dive
and that was uh this is a real story
dude
fake plant but it'll i'm sure it'll take
well yeah
but so when he and he loved doing that
oh yeah yeah but he would always
he wouldn't come out every day but when
randy started walking up
all the kids knew he about to it's about
uh
and he would do a huge come on randy
well everybody went and he was like kind
of a a rogue
he wasn't attached to a church like
these are from first baptism
from first prayers randy just we was at
six baptists i think he
anyway so he said he said he promised
if every kid
memorized psalm 23
he would shave his head at the end
because he had like a law
he had like a long he was a oh yeah dude
yeah and he goes i will shake
my head he's an organ donor yeah 100
this kid i think his name was nathan and
james
oh yeah two of my buddies if they could
quote psalm 23 he would shave his head
and this kid got up there nailed it
and
it was like in a pavilion type situation
oh yeah a lot of pavilions yeah a lot of
people
said they were covered but not at the
sides yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one